[Music]
oh
[Music]
so
hey steven it's dave
landau
third chair
i'm really sorry that i ate your last
build bar i have self-control issues
with food and everything else
i wrote you a song
i hope you like it
i'm just a little bit plump in the
middle ate the last build bar hot off
the griddle sweet and yummy cocoa junk
food a methadone
deep fried banana cream pie mouth full
of delicious chocolate mint ooey gooey
candy coated fingerprints
low net carbs so technically still keto
sweet sweet marshmallow
[Music]
got i'm from built bar shop
so for my tummy's gonna pop
eat too much
it's a lot
in your mouth something it's not
protein
[Music]
sweet marshmallow
don't leave me alone with
bilbao or steven don't leave me alone
with desserts don't leave me alone with
desserts
shouldn't have done that
it's on you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that's a that's and i can't contain my
excitement sip
because today's a good day well okay
it's a bad day because the guy who
leaked it or girl or z is a dick
but yeah what was leaked
is big news of course i'm talking about
roe v wade and the uh well the alleged
but it seems like supreme court ruling
on that uh that's going to be coming
down coming down the pike look
this is something where a lot of people
are talking about it a lot of people are
missing some key points that this is uh
roe v wade has been bad law so i want to
make sure that i know we have some of
you right now if you're watching or
you're listening on audio on on apple
used to be itunes
when i was your age uh or on android or
on spotify that you may be
pro abortion pro-choice to whatever
capacity you believe that you are
that's not necessarily what we're
talking about today of course i am
pro-life i make uh you know there's
there's no look i'm very
i make my biases known as as
apparently as i can uh but my question
to you is this before we get to the law
of it we are going to show some clips
here today from the meltdown and uh give
you some there's some exclusive updates
here we may know who the leaker is
as this comes in it's 9 21 central god's
time so 10 21 eastern uh we may be
finding out more or more about who
leaked this uh spoiler alert definitely
a liberal this is an intimidation tactic
but before we get to
tat
stroke before we get to that uh my
question to you is why do you think that
the left
why do you think when you see all these
feminists why do you think they're so
they're so vehemently pro-kill these
people killing babies and i mean
actually wanting to abort babies up
until and including birth these people
those are the people i'm talking about
that's not most of the country i
understand that and most of the country
is not pro-life to the extent of you
know not allowing for exceptions uh of
incest and and rape that's not what i'm
talking about i'm talking about if you
look at the reaction today from the
mainstream left
what other reason can you have other
than people shouting their abortion and
talking about
colorado for example virginia these laws
and praising them outside of honestly
evil
evil
because we're at a point where look
people know it's a baby if it's 32 weeks
if it's 34 weeks there's no denying that
there's no scientific argument at that
point and they say well it should be
taxpayer-funded abortion-on-demand
period
that's why we're here what's happening
today
leftists who happen to be watching media
matters hello is
your fault
this is the pendulum swinging
you've reached too far and i just my
question is i want to know why it's hard
for me to get into your mind i mean this
isn't the cell
so uh that being said since we are
discussing something that has been
leaked and youtube is selective on what
kind of investigative journalism is
allowed if this is not on youtube you
don't see us on youtube you can go to
rumble or mug club monday through
thursday 10 a.m eastern we're available
there nothing would make me more happy
nothing would make nothing would trill
me more greatly than for you to go to
rumble or mug club
and to shoot you
so
uh we'll get to that in a second uh a
lot of info today it's mainly going to
be in the supreme court and also the
history of roe v wade and why rbg
uh was against the ruling of roe v wade
but first let's introduce of course
gerald a is with child
gerald b how are you sir
oh he's surprised and he's surprised in
the leak
he is dumbfounded he is stunned to find
out
that alito is not amongst his uh blow up
brethren stunning and uh you know
you know him you love him uh at landau
dave the quickest man on his feet and
he's doing some dates here this weekend
in uh springfield missouri lincoln
nebraska go to lot of credit dot com
tour to buy tickets dave landa how are
you ahoy good how about you sir i'm
doing well um i did my own makeup we
secretly wear that on this show and boy
can you tell all right go on
actually no you look rosy do i yeah hey
then i don't wear makeup no he doesn't
wear makeup
what about one of them yeah he if he
just wakes up like this he doesn't need
to put on his face i look like a cop
yeah all right anyway or in the taking
back sunday parody that's coming down
the pike
someone said you looked like emo hitler
well yeah
yeah the full mustache one yeah he's
like not the handlebar not that well
because it wasn't it was just coming in
the
handlebar hitler would be good instead
of the toothbrush mustang it's a bold
choice the mustache uh check your mug by
the way because it does smell a little
bit in the studio so just just check it
we had an incident here yesterday yet
amber heard creating she's been creating
copycat poopers
i'd like to say too i uh
i think it's uh it's not a man's place
to talk about abortion uh until apple
decided to make the pregnant man emoji
yes so that's what i enjoy is that the
woke left is like you can't talk about
it right but also men can get pregnant
it's like you really ruined yourself
right yeah exactly kind of like title
nine sure uh with dicks yes
all right
the rules have changed
also i would recommend if you have kids
watching with you today uh it's not a
trigger warning this is a strong pg-13
because we will be discussing the
dismemberment and uh and tube sucking of
babies just to be clear so it's you know
not necessarily age appropriate i'm not
a florida public school teacher
no
so before we get to that uh of course we
know the big news supreme court uh it
has some
and when i before i so let me give you
it has the worst among us
uh middle-aged
liberal women upset
but we all just get angry
get angry are you guys angry
at least a church mouse would be quiet
nothing going on in your life
well not a creature was stirring not
even a church [ __ ] yeah
she really thought that church mouse
she's like i know i'm gonna say i'm not
a church mouse and then when someone
came back with something she wasn't
ready for she's like i am not a church
mouse it's
also just an outdated stupid thing to
say where everybody's like you just lost
touch years ago yeah this is why you're
angry and no one's touched you in years
you're not a church mouse you're a
satanic temple shrew
there's just
the guy in the salmon shirt who's like
i'm a straight white guy who's here to
settle this it's like stay home yeah are
you angry again waste of a night i know
yeah yeah are you upset yeah they're
upset that's all that's all they do i
would like to express being upset but
that might uh exhibit toxic masculinity
so i will let the raging karen who says
she's not a church mouse do my speaking
for me but you have anything else other
than she's going with church mouth okay
great i didn't can't believe she pulled
that one out yeah i don't know what it
means either yeah i don't know exactly
is there an epidemic of mice in church
i'm just not i think she was fighting
with somebody else that was on her side
yeah yeah that's well because they don't
really have a side they're just
psychotic and mad at everyone and
everyone they're on the same side not a
church and by the way speaking of mice
looking at that you know she was wearing
those she was wearing those white pants
it seems like someone cut off her tail
with a carving knife so hey
build bar
dot com uh we just said you know we had
the intro there uh by the way name that
film reference for people who don't know
they are delicious it's the end of
moneyball built that you just ruined it
oh oh it was a game that's right
all right built.com and you entered the
promo code crowder15
you're like my mom freaked out my mom
when she tells jokes she tells the punch
line first because she's concerned
people have stopped listening
it wasn't moneyball no is that better
that's fine did i fix the problem threw
him off the scent
built.com crowder15 look i said there's
no one needs like protein bars but they
are delicious it really has it's like
you put it really well it's like junk
food methadone it really does sort of
it's it's a tiered process yeah because
you're trying to wean yourself off the
bad stuff yeah it's like chocolate uh
suboxone yes yeah very well put yes but
then you know but don't become an addict
you don't want to you replace a bad
habit with a good habit that's what i've
used built bar for and i'm down uh since
the surgery about uh 35 pounds that's
what you have to do rewire the brain to
do something positive to replace the
negative right like my brain just it's
more like a piston engine where it's
like oh problem this one goes down and
another one's popular right like
whack-a-mole yeah none of them go away
all the time mine's more like a turbine
um in that uh it's not quite a jet
but you know i can fly a little lower so
there's some versatility
ah
there's one person there with an fa
pilot
i like this i like the pilot themed
humor i have a small plane i enjoy it
all right so look a supreme court this
is this is what's in the news today but
i think that some people are missing
some some important some key details
here and when people say find common
ground i don't believe you can find
common ground in the lie i've talked
about this before but you can find
common ground on agreeing to the terms i
mean people have done that in war for
crying out loud so agreeing to the terms
as far as
what constitutes good law this is where
you had someone like ruth bader ginsburg
who was able to agree with people like
alito on at least the legal premise of
roe v wade this is why we are where we
are now there's been a leak this morning
we have a hunch as to who the leaker is
um
but according to a draft majority
opinion this was obtained by politico
they are now voting to strike down roe v
wade
now is there i have a question is there
punishment for the leaker because it
seems between the fbi cia this there's a
lot going on in the government that
should not be out and available to the
public the way that it's been they would
but they're too busy prosecuting the q
and on shaman oh good yes i forgot
that's son of a guy yeah also uh
downloading hardcore pedophile
pornography this is its research yes
it's simply research the p townsend
defense yes
the daniel day lewis method pornography
so uh the draft decision just for people
who don't know it comes from uh dobbs
versus uh jackson's women's health
organization now this is this was a case
in mississippi uh it was a 15-week ban
extremists uh 15-week ban and so there
was an organization that lobbied for it
and so obviously they were sued and they
said hey you lobbied for this now you're
infringing my rights this guy then
you know went up to the supreme court
now the majority opinion this is
according to the leak which we have
every reason to believe not because it
comes from politico of course not but
because it's been confirmed also by
other sources um the majority opinion
written by justice alito uh wrote
we hold that row and casey must be
overruled it is time to heed the
constitution and return to the uh to
return the issue of abortion to the
people's elected
representatives now what does that mean
we'll talk about this more this means
that it just goes to the states so by
the way the states that have these crazy
radical abortion laws no i'm not talking
about you know viability bans like in
places like texas i'm talking about
places that allow abortions up until
eight nine months
that right now that's not going to be
affected this is going to kick it to the
state so guess what you just you might
you might have to you know you might
have to cross state lines in your datsun
well yeah they sort of reacted
immediately as if it had all been taken
away and that's not the case it's kind
of like the twitter thing
immediately you think you know the
outcome and before researching any of it
you just freak out yes you freak out
because you're not a church mouse right
and you'll still be able to get
abortions except tom selleck will be the
spokesperson and they'll be called
reverse character yes
listen
this isn't my first rodeo
i've used stirrups before yes
i wouldn't uh lie to you about taking
your baby this is not an attempt to
steal your baby yes it is
yes it is tom selleck
he's just taking it out of the crib yeah
he's mine yeah
first magnum primary physician well
primary percentage anyway okay so anyway
elito also noted uh an appropriate joke
he noted that uh look the right to an
abortion this is the thing we'll talk
about roe v wade it's nowhere in the
constitution this is one of those issues
to have talked about in the past people
go separation of christian state
separation of church and state look i
understand the principle and so it's
sort of become uh a sound bite you know
one that oprah would like
uh but it's not in the constitution and
then people take a sound bite that isn't
in the constitution and they
misinterpret it you're talking about the
separate you're talking about the first
amendment the act just the phrase
separation of church and state doesn't
appear now what the idea of the first
amendment expresses is of course they
left the church of england that the
government would be out of the church
running business it never was intended
to prevent for example elected
representatives from expressing their
faith it prevents them from enforcing
their faith and particularly a state
denomination we've talked about this you
can look at letter letter b was written
from thomas jefferson to the danbury
baptist so there's historical precedent
not only do you have the constitution
but you have supporting documents and
there are a lot of them the same with
the second amendment now when the left
says that there's a constitutional right
to abortion not only is it not in the
constitution there's nothing even
supporting that and that's not why roe v
wade exists so let me read again alito
he said we hold that roe v wade in case
must be overruled the constitution makes
no reference to abortion and no such
right meaning the right to abortion
itself is implicitly protected by any
constitutional provision and it should
be noted that uh even though he is uh
pro-life uh justice alito is ironically
up
[Music]
i'm just shaking
no no it's like dirty work when he takes
him out to moon the movie line and then
just stops the car puts in the parking
brake i thought he was going to keep
driving
sorry so uh let me give you some other
news here before we get to the wonderful
reactions from the left because that is
fun uh
thomas gorsuch kavanaugh and of course
coney barrett uh are going to join alito
this is all from the leak we don't know
with 100 certainty uh the majority
decision now of course kagan briar
sotomayor have uh dissented
sotomayor is an idiot
now
roberts we don't know uh
sounds delicious
weird name but delightful yeah she's
also fine
yes she's quite plain
and she's pro-life so you know she's
fertile i took coney to coney
just lost the pro-life card did he do
the grease motion under the dock yes but
this is woman oh no that's a really
weird woman that's a that's a bunch of
room
i like my women you like your women
curvy i like them foley
they wash up on the beach they're
mermaids yes they're sea cows yeah
they're humanities they're manatees
half man half manatee yeah but they're
mine
it's like a it's like a an ocean
tar
i want to keep it pg-13 but i should
really have one of those yes
so now let's get to before we get some
of uh get to some more of the uh some
more of the ins and outs here of course
as expected and by this what i mean when
i say as expected i don't just mean that
it's coming from the left i don't just
mean the type of reaction but that the
people who are uh delivering these
reactions also look
exactly how you would expect them to
enjoy
it could also become a criminal offence
the reason they're keeping this focused
on abortion rights is that look there's
lots of people who are ever sleep with a
woman with a goatee i don't say anything
about it i like to wake up next to clown
smash mouth way more i wish the doctor
would flip some of this
so these are not tears like sadness
these are tears of rage
your diet is the abortion
yeah well okay here's the thing that
might have been too far no it's not too
far it's not too far at all it's ad
hominem it's entirely appropriate
because all of them are uh scary now
well especially the first one it's like
what you worry about
guys
you were what are you like you don't
have to worry about that no
well that's what i have a theory it's
always really really unattractive women
who for example they [ __ ] about cat
calling they [ __ ] about abortion here's
the thing i know there are plenty of
attractive women who uh who believe in
the right to abortion that being said
women who are attracted this is just a
theory just to be clear this is just
this is just conjecture okay
i'm not a doctor on ugly chicks no
they
they look like because attractive women
who support abortion they still you know
they're often because they can have they
can sleep with whoever they want well
they yeah they're interested in the
choice but they're predominantly
concerned with usually attracted women
like hey i'm not a [ __ ] you know i mean
that's like hey i'm not a [ __ ] so they
typically don't want to go out and shout
their abortion these often women want to
be like look so everybody wants to cat
call me and i'm having so much sex that
i have to have all these abortion you
guys everyone's like
sure
somebody uh yeah you're walking down the
street in a construction worker yelling
move so you can see a hotter woman it's
not cat called exactly
this just starts jesus starts aiming his
pneumatic drill
yeah it's that's i mean look like it's
like elena dunham's like oh my gosh i
hope no i'm at this party i'm super
drunk i took muscle relaxers i hope
nobody rapes me like you're good yeah
you're fine nobody nobody wants consent
have you noticed the playpen go in there
enjoy everyone hates you yes
you're an awful person you're a terrible
terrible person it's awful
um they even by the way they even
started supporting outside we showed you
this but we have some more uh the
supreme court already
[Applause]
[Laughter]
oh
[Applause]
okay
uh first off let's break down sexual
fascism this is what they're using
nowadays i mean we could probably bring
up the definition a little bit later i'm
going by rote but primarily the concern
with fascism is them forcing you to
conform right by the threat of force
having to conform with a political
persuasion
a point of view a lifestyle is dictated
by a tyrannical government can someone
please can someone make an argument and
if you make a good argument here we'll
pin the comment
on youtube
how
kicking this back to giving the rights
back to the states to determine their
own abortion how
that is sexual fascism who is forcing
you to conform to their view of
sexuality here
is anyone are forbidding you from having
sex no
are they forbidding you from having sex
with as many partners as you want no
are they forbidding you from having sex
a specific way or purchasing a
vietnamese sex hammock i can testify no
so
how is there sexual fascism oh wait it
is a nice hammock yes it doesn't take a
nap on it i didn't know it was a sex
hammock well it's also because it's
supportive it's good it's nice
it came with that wonderful milking
table it's like sleeping on a cloud yes
it's great
also has stirrups
what's right in there so i i don't
understand where's the sexual fascism
coming from oh wait hold on a second and
this is something whether you agree with
my point of view or not
even as it relates to what happens after
you've had sex irresponsibly and
couldn't be bothered to purchase a 25
cent rubber at a truck stop or use birth
control or if you work at hobby lobby
take advantage of the 16 forms of birth
control available which you complained
about as a violation of human rights on
par with the holocaust even after all of
that we still believe in many many
options
if you are with child four we just don't
want the fifth what's that we believe in
chastity
abstinence
contraception
parenthood or adoption just not
the fifth
face you might not you might not agree
with me but guess what
that's not fascism
just like 16 forms of birth control at
hobby lobby
but which is actually there are very few
businesses that
that actually
subsidize birth control to the degree of
hobby lobby
i don't get the 20. it doesn't matter
that's not fascism everyone remembers
pol pot yeah you you have 16 choices no
of course not that's not how it works i
just this is the term that they use
sexual fascism and it doesn't even take
into account that there's a legal
argument here their hero
they're heroin rbg said it was bad law
so uh one of them may have all of this
figured out uh where this is one of my
favorites without roe v wade this is
this is
this is a brilliant idea maybe people
should just stop having sex hear me out
if they overturn roe v wade
humans that possess
uteruses
should collectively get together
and never have sex with men again
some of you guys were on the fence
already about it
this would be the best way to protest
this deal transies it is you made me
this way
[Laughter]
she has to go through to great lengths
too she's like humans
without a uterus because there's one
ncaa swim champ like
what about me what about me
can i have an abortion
sure yeah whatever you call it whatever
whatever that is
they can't stop tripping over their own
prosthetic dicks
now sorry we can't do the heart
transplant we're doing a fake abortion
two rooms down yes yes
yes oh well
legs and the stirrups okay we are going
to of course
uh into the
birth canal let me just move these
testicles out of the way all right and
oh yeah oh yeah okay here we go i don't
have an appendix anymore like the final
scene and man on the moon with andy
kaufman yeah let's pull out a baby like
a clown with one of those ropes but this
is where they are there's no way does
how can you say that your abortion is
about supporting women when you're
allowing men to beat the crap out of
women in sports
when you're along men in women's only
spaces let's be honest about this this
isn't about women's rights women i hope
you are seeing this and i say this
because look the only demographic left
that has not made a wild swing toward
the right this includes latinos this
includes blacks i'm not saying that
they're all a majority republican but a
significantly higher portion and yes a
majority of latinos here the only group
that hasn't swung is suburban women
and then when you talk with most of
these women
about these issues they invariably find
out that they're far more conservative
than they realize because women are
often more agreeable that's what we love
about you and so often women want to
avoid topics that will create conflict
things like abortion and so they go
along with not all women to be clear
but statistically if you look at the
polling data a lot of women seem to sort
of be led by the nose on abortion they
believe oh sexual fascism oh my body my
choice
this is something this is an opportunity
to educate people that people have said
where's the hope where's the silver
lining there's a lot of it not only with
twitter last week not only with the
giant polling shifts
but what you're seeing now with with
this this is going to give you an
opportunity to educate people go down to
these protests in your city go down and
talk with them and if they keep yelling
that they're not a church mouse find
someone you know reasonable and you know
like a like a six
so
some lawmakers
that's not what you wanna no take home
if you look at this lawmakers you have
they've already taken a twitter calling
for uh codifying row into law so you
have bernie sanders where he said uh uh
congress must pass legislation that
codifies ruby wade as the law of the
land in this country now
son of a [ __ ] if there aren't 60 votes
in the senate to do it
and there are not we must end the
filibuster and pass it with 50.
[Laughter]
then you have i find i'm trying to find
a way to always bring it actually that
that was ridiculous so it made perfectly
perfect sense to do it in the late great
gift voice you have elizabeth warren i
don't know if you know this uh
noted not native american elizabeth
warren but my
my uh uh
kung pao chow yes my gun gotcha yes i
realize that's asian good point no you
are the panda express of native
americans you really are your tpp
whatever
cookbook
uh
lessons she wrote this she tweeted this
an extremist supreme court is poised to
overturn roe v wade and impose its
far-right unpopular views on the entire
country it's time for the million to
support the constitution abortion rights
to stand up and make their voices heard
we are not going back not ever and of
course uh noted uh favorite
representative who is googly i repeat
googly aoc said people elected democrats
precisely so we could lead in perilous
moments like these to codify by the way
she knows perilous moments because she
was four miles away when there was a
bomb threat once i know terrifying she
almost died yeah i'm told exactly it's
like it's like someone like i was there
the boston marathon bombing really where
were you well i was in uh i was in uh i
was in nantucket yeah queens jamaica
yeah
but i was i mean i was alive i mean i
guess at some point i was facing the
general direction of the boston marathon
bombing so i too had 9 11 rough day for
me oh were you there oh no
yeah
so how would oh yeah yeah but i almost i
couldn't pick up my dry cleaning yeah i
mean are you kidding there were places
that were closed it affects us all so
she wrote people aoc elected democrats
precisely so we could lead in pairless
moments like these to codify row hold
corruption accountable and have a
president who uses his legal authority
to break through congressional gridlock
on items from student debt to climate
okay
all right so look
before i move
sorry yes this is perilous student debt
i just love the compar why it it's an
issue to issue thing why oh do they
always drag in the dumbest [ __ ] um
anyway it's perilous language no it's
perilous you know why it's perilous
because these people don't have an
accuracy
they don't have an actual fight well
greg abbott's in a wheelchair they don't
have an actual fight so yeah that's what
happened in the beaches of normandy that
first scene of saving private
they're like seeing their friend
carrying around his arm going oh god i
hope i don't have a twenty thousand
dollar loan with unreasonable interest
on my basket weaving degree you have
nothing student debt don't go into debt
how about that
how about don't go oh climate well i
don't know look if you want to talk
about climate being look here's the
thing i get that you care about climate
more and i think that you think that
people shouldn't have to pay off their
own loans more that's more important to
you but can you at least acknowledge can
you at least acknowledge because i
understand why people on the left women
who don't really know what abortion is
who don't want know when viability
actually takes place who don't
understand that there's new dna that you
do not have 20 fingers 20 toes that if
you have a boy that you don't have a
vagina and a penis right
i understand that many women don't know
this and so they they believe that they
are pro-choice i get where they're i
think they're wrong can you acknowledge
that if someone particularly scientists
particularly every biology textbook
that's ever existed right the definition
of where life begins
can you acknowledge that to someone who
believes let's say a 32 week old baby
that's being aborted in colorado
can you acknowledge that to them that's
more pressing
than a 1.6 degree increase in the next
100 years can you can you at least
understand why to these people it's
pressing
i just it's not about finding common
ground
it's about just trying to understand the
other perspective which by the way is
why we use liberal sources you can check
all references available at
lightworkcutter.com so here's the thing
that they're trying to claim
they believe that overturning uh uh is
is uh
it'll set a precedent that's completely
unheard of by the way no problem with
packing the supreme court and they'll
try and point to but they don't really
understand exactly what happened when
the supreme court was expanded because
of the country and population but here
they try and act as though this is
something if we overturn roe v wade
everything else is going to be
overturned because this hasn't happened
before the supreme court has overturned
over 230 rulings in its history
230 is not a mundane detail michael
that's quite a bit yeah and by the way
you're saying well these are two of them
we're guilty these are just these are
just small decisions that's what you
might want
these are just you know these aren't
pivotal uh wedge issues like this um no
no you're wrong and by the way many of
those overturnings you supported because
they reflected your position liberals so
you have brown versus the board of
education that ruled uh well this is one
that i think is actually a good thing
that racially segregated schools were
unconstitutional great that's one that
we can all agree with but then you have
lawrence versus texas and you have um
obergefell versus hodges which ruled uh
that bans on same-sex marriages were
unconstitutional where were you guys on
the overturning there
my point is this
we understand the rules to the game here
you have to play by them
you can't just throw a hissy fit when it
doesn't go your way that's the worst
kind of player
soccer
so
what is actually being overturned and by
the way dave and i have had
conversations on this dave isn't this
isn't on the same side of the political
spectrum entirely entirely that i am as
far as pro-life i think you hold a
reasonable position i think some of them
i disagree with them we'll probably have
a conversation today on mud club about
it yeah it's not a i come from a
different place and it's not the but i
mean this is a different animal that
we're talking about right right now it's
not it's not what they're making it into
no that's exactly which is exactly what
they do the second like we said they
hear a word or they hear something's
going to happen they jump on it
immediately pretend it's something that
it's not and they gaslight the other
side it's all they do it's their tactic
like church mouse a bit like church
mouse it's kind of like when you watch
world star hip-hop you ever see when
when when and
what are you saying black people when
they get into a fight and then it's like
you know how it's about to come to blows
yes is when they repeat the same thing
over and over like they're talking trash
before that and a lot of zingers and
then all of a sudden they're just like
yeah yeah yeah you a [ __ ] and then now
it's no longer like you a [ __ ] yeah
your mom's it's just like yeah you a
[ __ ] and they get up close like you a
[ __ ] you a [ __ ] you know by the sixth
you a [ __ ] there's something coming now
when he starts repeating himself that's
when it gets dangerous in the danger
zone both cause fight and flight all of
a sudden it's not flight it's fight
everything else in your world is gone
including the ability to like
rip on someone yep and it's just an
attack there was one i think it was an
ultimate fighter was uh rampage jackson
versus a guy named rashad evans so oh
guess that guess the ethnicity and uh
holy he's going you a [ __ ] you a [ __ ]
was shot you a [ __ ] yeah go ahead and
treat me like a [ __ ] you a [ __ ] go
ahead and treat me like a [ __ ] you a
[ __ ] go ahead and treat me and then you
see the coaches getting like all right
separate we know where this is going
stand back marshall wallace
all right so roe v wade uh federally
enshrined abortion
okay and it was predicated on the idea
of viability and here's also the problem
with that
viability changes
as technology advances you can go back
and watch the change my minds that we've
done oh viability is the argument so is
a baby uh more valuable at lennox hill
in manhattan than they are in the
the hills of tennessee
because they have better technology
what's viable there it's not so does
geography determine whether it's a life
or not
i certainly think nine months does
that would be i think it's a good
jumping off point i think it's fair to
say that that that's just disgusting to
me and what i don't understand is how
you think that this is compassion for
people while you don't have compassion
for a person as well right it's insane
to me so roe v wade enshrined viability
into law and so basically what it means
is the first trimester a state can't
regulate abortion okay that's it
uh now the court determined uh here's
the thing it's not based on a
constitutional right to abortion despite
what not church mouse would have you
believe it's the due process clause of
the 14th amendment protects the right to
privacy against state action it's
basically a technicality about the right
of privacy and a patient and their
doctor it does not roe v wade does not
say that abortion is a constitutional
right
okay and unfortunately what happens as
you see with laws a lot of the time
something gets ruled on the supreme
court and then you see smaller courts
that interpret it some way and it's a
basterization of the law and then ends
up bouncing but so this this is the
problem that we've run into this is why
roe v wade is something that even ruth
bader ginsburg said is a problem we
should probably take another run at it
and do it properly so
it's about a woman's right to privacy
and this is how alito referred to the
case in his majority opinion he said roe
expressed the feeling that the 14th
amendment was a provision that did the
work but its message seemed to be that
the abortion right could be found
somewhere in the constitution and that
specifying its location was not of
paramount importance so it was let me
read that again
that the right to abortion the abortion
right could be found somewhere in the
constitution
and that specifying its exact location
was not of paramount importance i will
say that's a little bit
passive-aggressive yeah it really is but
i like that he did it right that's
passive-aggressive justice alito and i
did that about you so you know who else
understood how flawed it was again i was
sort of
like you i already i spoiled it mr
moneybag i'm sorry about the moneyball
but i did the same thing with rbg i
already said it so this is what she
wrote
doctrinal
no people don't realize that she said dr
lim's two swiftly shaped experienced
teachers may prove unstable she also
said the unelected judges decided this
question for the country and never mind
that the issue was in flux in the state
legislatures so she wanted to approach
abortion under the equal protection
clause and she knew that framing it
around privacy wouldn't hold up in the
long run so hey she got one right
that is true
sorry
sorry liberals
your hero's rubbing you from the grave
you need to you need you need to get the
snidely whip can you think you can grow
it that much sorry you feminist scary
feminists
[Laughter]
she's haunting you
she's the ghost of christmas future
she's a specter
a specter of death so rbg now we get to
the leak
the notorious the notorious rpg yeah
they really made her into yeah i know it
was ridiculous or they were like look
how fit she is that netflix documentary
oh yeah when she's like barely holding
up a one-pound weight and yeah throwing
up broth yeah she's doing great exactly
she's probably gonna be around for at
least another 10 minutes she's like
lifting a rubber band you hear snap yeah
i'll get you another rubber band now
that was my
ligament
just another toe
ironically she did look like a church
mouse she did yeah she was half
half demon half church mouse unfairly
quiet especially on a plane sitting next
to a minority she'd be like oh i'm
scared yeah
i shouldn't have flown spirit all right
i just thought i'd save a buck or two
yes i'm so scared
not worth it
they make me pay for my carry-on anyways
this is a stampede to get off this blue
so ruth bader ginsburg agrees with alito
this is something that a lot of people
may not necessarily realize now let's
get to the leak okay let me explain this
uh not a big fan of the leak
i'm glad to hear what we've heard
but let me give you a guess i'm pretty
sure the leak is from a leftist why this
is an intimidation tactic now when you
talk about unprecedented that nothing
has been overturned that's what we call
in the biz
wrong
right 230 examples of you being wrong
in this case we actually have something
that is unprecedented as far as a
security breach a leak
of a ruling of the supreme court that's
a really big deal and of course you see
it and just like clockwork you see the
protests and you know it's going to get
violent because
it's never not
that's why i'm guessing that it's a
liberal so let's read from politico it
says no no draft decision in modern
history of the court has been disclosed
publicly while a case was still pending
you don't say but didn't you leak it
it totally did
i said yeah no this has never happened
this is really dangerous
so it's because of you it would be
dangerous no you did it oh you're kind
of solely responsible for all the danger
that's brewing up right yeah before it
comes out well the leak came to us yeah
so i didn't leak it it's just we
we leaked it yeah that's all we leaked
it after it was leaked
what's the trouble
so the going theory right now and this
is sort of breaking will keep you
updated it's almost eleven o'clock
eastern uh the only people who would
have had access to it
you know unlike hunter biden's nine hard
drives or um
we found this out swell well
swallow unfortunately
him and the chinese spy had an only fans
did they didn't require a lot of digging
oh just an 11 a month subscription which
seems high yeah it does seem high i
wouldn't want to watch especially
because he farts during it yes i know
well you know everyone has their thing
anytime there's a mic around don't want
to be a sexual fascist but that's gross
so the going theory right now is that it
was a clerk for justice sonia sotomayor
that before we go to the quote
the stupidest of the judges that's how i
refer to her yes
uh let me read a quote here on twitter a
person called
amit jane clerks for supreme court
justice sonia sotomayor as a yale
student
is it jane or yane well hopefully
they'll be going to yale
yeah blasted
yale
or supporting brett kavanaugh's
nomination
jane or yane i don't know as i'm reading
this as it's breaking was quoted in a
2017 political piece by josh gerstein
today gerstein published the draft uh
opinion on roe so
[ __ ] of a feather you know that's
that's why it's the best guess at this
point
let me give to you why the leak matters
okay and i understand that sometimes you
know leak or sometimes there's a
difference between a whistleblower and a
leaker
the supreme court has actually been
referred to and i think we have from the
chicago tribune as the last leak proof
institution and again because it's very
very small it's closed circuit yes and
that needs to be by design you know as
opposed to city legislatures like in
seattle or portland who get pressured
due to the violence to defunding the
police and then they go oh we really
shouldn't have done that this is now a
hellscape yeah you don't want that
happening at the supreme court
at all you don't want these people it's
supposed to be separate that's why can
you guys hey
we'll read this in the chat later but
pause it if you're watching this on the
archive by the way smash that like
button that does help with the algorithm
the best thing you can do is smash the
like button
you can comment
you can share all that stuff uh
anyway doesn't matter lastly proof
institution i forgot what i was gonna
say because i'm just i'm still thinking
about uh well they are the last legends
yeah yane is not a name yeah
neither is coney i mean
off the yane
yane
cocaine so here's the thing leaks are
incredibly oh that's what i was gonna
ask you three branches of government can
you name it don't use a cheat sheet with
schoolhouse rock
again leaks are a real problem to the
process of deliberation this is
something
that uh people
it's just look there's consistent
there's inconsistency on both sides let
me be clear about this okay
it's not really
you're not breaking new ground by
accusing someone of being a hypocrite
because everyone is a hypocrite and you
do have people who praise whistleblowers
and then condemn whistleblowers
depending on who it is okay got it
however this has never happened
ever
and there's a reason for it
let me read you from politico
deliberations on controversial cases
have in the past been a fluid process
and i mean that in the actual sense of
fluid not you can be whatever gender you
want depending on when the clock strikes
12. it says justices can and sometimes
do change their votes as draft opinions
circulate and major decisions can be
subject to multiple drafts and vote
trading sometimes until just days before
decision is unveiled the court's holding
will not be final until it is published
likely in the next two months look this
is one of those things where secrecy is
it's of paramount there are things that
you have that of course we have the
right to know for example um
if american citizens are being throttled
or silenced on social media oh private
company but if they're being throttled
or silenced on social media as per the
directions of the united states
government these are things you have a
right to know
if you voted more than once this is
something good point yes yeah just
throwing it out there yeah not that that
would ever happen right kate can we uh
write down guys on control can we write
down uh for next election anyone here
who wants to vote uh more than once i
don't want to okay
so i vote three times well yeah i mean
you do the absentee and then you do the
other absentee yeah well they send me
three it's kind of like when i used to
go and get the price match guarantee
yeah they say we price match now we go
to one place say hey they probably they
beat your price and they're like well
then we have to beat their price and i
go back so they beat your price i know
you stop at four different churches in
my area that have uh voting yep
wonderful yep also uh trash bins
yeah where they tell you to put uh if
you don't like who you're yeah all the
pamphlets you get for the other team
yeah exactly the side yeah and that's
where you find a bunch of votes so
they're sorry i'm just learning as this
goes there are things you have to write
a little off and i guess never but i'm
just watching like i i didn't know all
about this until yesterday to be honest
there are things you have the right to
know for example when people say we have
a right to know everything as it relates
to national security no geraldo rivera
shouldn't give away coordinates so my
point here is there are things that need
to be kept private
and certainly deliberation between
judges which is supposed to be a
separate branch of government they are
supposed to be siloed by design they are
supposed to be completely devoid of
outside influence
and this is why conservatives tend to
support originalists they are supposed
to be beholden to the text of the law so
there's inconsistency on all sides as it
relates to whistleblowers however in
this case it's unprecedented and it is
very clearly meant to be an intimidation
tactic because they want to try and
pressure the supreme court they want
them to be afraid they want them to make
a decision now where am i getting this
from where am i getting this from that
oh the left side seeks to try and
intimidate through the bully pulpit
through the power of the mob i don't
know black lives matter riots i don't
know antifa
i mean it is an opinion the only reason
you would leak the document yeah
what's the other purpose
i mean you're going to find out in two
months i mean that's really what it is
exactly
it's not like you're saving somebody
it's not like you're saving somebody's
life by leaking something as far as uh i
don't know a hostage situation or if
there are war crimes being committed
that's not what's happening here it's
you're leaking something that there's
there's a an opinion coming down the
pike that you don't like and you have
made very clear leftists in the past you
will be violent
to oppose and you're also ignorant about
so it's very easy for you to go out and
just start protesting and you know
eventually that
leads to death destruction and
everything else that we've seen well i
think too you know this is one thing
where if you look at the recent polls
where you see uh you know what let me go
to cnn really quickly but i want to go
remind me to go back to the polls of uh
national security and biden doing very
poorly on right now go to the polls of
tuban yes
happens of this magnitude from the court
the opinions are never indicated or
released at any point before decision
day we're still waiting to hear if and
when the supreme court might comment on
this we were outside the chief justice's
home john roberts earlier this morning
he was asked sure he appreciated that
if there would be any investigation am i
the only one who at the very least i
don't know if that's so awesome
journalistically difficult but [ __ ]
it's just
like yeah i just hate that we were
outside of his home uh i was hiding in
the hot tub and uh you know he didn't
want to talk to me so i was on his swing
in the yard yes it's a nice playscape
yes exactly i was holding a blow dryer
with a scope
and he didn't seem to like that very
much so back to you tubin
stelter was on all fours on his front
lawn eating a pizza like a dog yes
with a woman
with a woman what yeah is going yeah
straight stelter is great let's see what
cnn has to say about this because we
just gave you some context this exact
quote on alito reference is available
let's see if they give context or if
they just go into hysterics elected
representatives politico releasing this
draft opinion 98 pages from justice
alito joined crucially by releasing is
the term they used releasing releasing
means it's a plan this isn't a pr
release it's a leak
officially it would uh send a seismic
wave all over and it's a crime
republican
it's a crime somebody should be held
responsible completely eliminate the
right to abortion so they are
practically eliminating the right to
abortion yeah so we just had what we
just told you it's a leak and they said
a release and of course this sends it
back to the states and they just said
we'll practically eliminate the right to
an abortion that's how they just framed
it on the most trusted name in news are
you paying attention yet let's hear
their experts let's see uh resting
terror oh look it's human oh hey great
yeah hey i thought i heard flapping i
guess it's if you don't have if you have
a penis no right to an opinion unless
you are chafing it on a webcam yes of
course unless you're using it in every
conference call that's fine
but by its decision to take the
mississippi case in the first place but
how shocking is this draft who do you
still have a job
you were masturbating on camera good
morning it's shocking in just about
every way uh how it would roll back a
half century of reproductive rights for
women uh how it was disclosed to the
american public late last night and in
terms of the substance that you ask
about disclosed
just released
disclosed
availed
carrier pigeon parenthood joan you
couldn't get pregnant with a time
machine it's so sharp and so strong that
i have a turkey
from the court is as harshly worded the
sentiment will probably be there but to
have five justices join what is a
such a strong statement against
precedent referring to
botox flawlessly authority by prior
supreme courts in allowing uh abortion
rights and also by the way
everything we've already addressed
they're using they're using right now
it'll go against precedent no it doesn't
it'll roll back all abortion rights no
it doesn't
no it doesn't we've already addressed it
so you're seeing in real time and this
is why look i'm not going to toot my own
hormone or the horn of researchers
producers here we almost exclusively
read liberal sources to try and prepare
you for what it is they're going to say
right now in real time they're saying it
by the way the most trusted masturbatory
experts let's hear uh what else they say
i really want to listen to this for a
little bit of how long roe v wade had
been entrenched that the supreme court
would not
uh
reverse it uh that was obviously before
donald trump put his three appointees on
the court oh it's true
that i think is off limits you know i
used to say oh they'd never reverse
obergefell uh which uh was the 2015 case
that made same-sex marriage uh a
fundamental constitutional right but now
uh i have to say i'm never going to say
never again
right it's happening under biden's watch
yeah i know the language may change
regardless of who he put in this in
draft so jeffrey do you remember me um
likely won't change right and you say
that this would be a seismic ship it was
and it's and again if this is the
opinion or something close to it is the
opinion it's worth remembering what the
basis of roe v was okay let's see if he
talks about the privacy um the casey
decisions were which is the right to
privacy good which these cons which the
justices found implicit he's thinking
clear-headedly because he cleaned out
the fight
and the right to privacy according to
the court for decades has protected
a right to purchase contraception it is
the right to have consensual sex with a
person of the same sex or of a different
sex it's related it's the right to
finish on a keyboard while on a live tv
show same sex or a different set you
have to have the silicone if there is no
more right to privacy in the
constitution daily this opinion seems to
suggest
um
this opinion doesn't rule let's look at
that he was on here's the thing he just
went a little bit further and this is
something you need to be prepared for
that's why i say there's a there's
there's the tree trunk and then there
are the branches you have the basic the
basic [ __ ] going ah no abortion
constitutional right then he just
acknowledged okay the right to privacy
understood but then he said that
overturning roe v wade
it's a tantamount to saying that the
constitution doesn't guarantee a right
to privacy no no no no no it's not
so you use the right premise and then
you veered no it's saying that abortion
isn't a constitutionally protected right
under the right to privacy does this
does this let me let me walk you through
this right now socratic method your
right to privacy you have the right to
do whatever you want in your own house
provided you're not breaking the law or
harming anybody does that change no you
have the right to watch what you want to
watch does that change no you have the
right to have sex with whoever you want
to have sex with and nobody else
has to uh interrogate you does that
change no you have the right to purchase
contraception and that's your private
right does that change no you have the
right to privacy between you and your
primary physician does that change no
you have the right to uh discuss with
your primary physician for example if
they are primary physician not for
example like planned parenthood have
never performed a mammogram in their
life you have the right to have a
mammogram does that change no
you have the right to not be spied upon
by the government does that well that
kind of has gone away with the patriot
act and of course we see from the left
but
in theory no the only thing that goes
away is this idea that abortion is a
constitutionally enshrined right under
the false premise of privacy that serial
masturbator sex offender just implied
that this decision
would
overturn the constitutional right to
privacy no one's talking about doing
away with the 14th amendment
so it seems like i'm angry
it's not that i'm angry because of
church mouses
out from the supreme court it's because
they they are so fundamentally dishonest
and this is this is the silver lining
the house of cards is coming down they
go look right now there's no one on
there to challenge them they have four
people say what you want about fox news
and i've said it a lot at the very least
they're gonna have a token democrat in
that quadrant view cnn doesn't even try
it's just lie lie and then a little bit
more of a manicured lie let's hear if
anyone here actually yeah it starts as a
truth and then it spins at the end every
time it's constant straw meaning
particularly women um it's hard to
predict right now defined woman
will come out
of the manners are going to be out there
saying
this is going to affect everything as
jeffrey was just saying before it's not
just the question of abortion it's the
question of where else the court will go
will the court backtrack on gay marriage
for example as joan was was questioning
so i think the democrats going to raise
these issues oh that's a shock that
they're bringing up all these other
things yeah upset people and riley
remains to be the public will they go
back against isn't it funny too that
they just implied that constitutionally
protected rights uh include abortion
and uh uh uh
banging a dude with a ring on
like let's just be like they say those
are constitutionally protected rights
and they also believe that a
constitutional right should be the right
to
student loans being forgiven they
believe that the right to not health
care not the right to maintain your own
health care hey that falls under the
right of privacy right now that's a
perfect example we believe in your right
to privacy you can purchase any health
care you want you can take care of your
health however you want you can have an
hsa you can have some kind of an
emergency account you can have a health
sharing program no they believe in what
they believe in socialized health care i
mean this is the mainstream platform of
the left we just quoted aoc and of
course bernie sanders has supported that
as well they believe those those things
are rights what about the second
amendment
so we have these absolute rights for
abortion and we'll get to what happens
with that in states like colorado and
states like virginia where
virginia where if a baby survives it
could still technically be aborted
thrown in a waste paper basket by the
way that's not extremist your champion
your star player barack obama voted
against the infant's born alive act in
illinois where babies who were surviving
abortions were not being given the
health care that other babies were being
given
he voted against just requiring doctors
to give give babies who managed to evade
the forceps the same kind of
healthcare's any other baby he voted
against it so i'm saying this is not a
fringe view this is a mainstream view of
the democratic platform all of these
things same-sex marriage and i'm not
even talking about where you're lying
another thing he didn't care about right
that's another he was against yes then
he was for it
same-sex marriage is a right student
loan forgiveness is a right health care
is a right abortion is a right what
about the second amendment that one's
pretty clear in other words find me grab
your constitution right now i'll make it
publicly available in the references i
shouldn't have to but many of you of
course haven't read it um
find me the right to an abortion
find it find me the right
to same-sex marriage find it find me the
right to forcing
a company to provide you with health
care free of charge at the taxpayer's
expense find it for me find me the right
to free university find me that right
hey i'll find you the ones that we fight
for every day the second amendment where
is it number two
shall not be infringed remember how i
talked about supporting documents that's
important too you don't just look at the
constitution
that's important it's pretty clear there
shall not be
infringed the rights of a free people
right people trying to make a big deal
out of the comment
uh about the militia yeah but then
they'll say that was old and it's
different now right isn't that the exact
same case with this well it would be the
same first amendment i don't see them
saying that well it doesn't apply to the
printing press it doesn't apply to you
know politico they don't care much about
that either no this is this is the point
is when we say first amendment they say
well private companies can do whatever
they want okay i get it but your press
your white house press secretary called
upon spotify and youtube and twitter and
facebook
you created
under the department of homeland
security meaning you can arrest people a
department to determine
what is misinformation here's also
something by the way
someone's right the first amendment
right to free speech
also protects their right to be wrong so
you can't silence them even if it's
misinformation unless it's deliberate
slander deliberate libel and we have
laws for that the second amendment is
pretty clear again we just said you said
right abortion right same-sex marriage
right education right health care second
amendment the right to bear arms shall
not be in french do you go to the
supporting documents oh wait a second
that's just back then it was just for
muskets wait you look i think it was a
madison who wrote a letter of mark
saying to a private ship well of course
yeah you can you guys can have cannons
well it's the second amendment it
protected cannons that's at least an
ar-15 you've heard me talk about this
before i feel like i'm repeating myself
but it needs repeating by the way they
also knew about
the puckle gun the pepper box revolver
the jira and there were plenty
of higher capacity or rapid fire weapons
that existed at that point the only
reason that they weren't they were too
expensive to produce for the same reason
that not all of you today have an elon
musk flamethrower it doesn't mean that
it doesn't exist so they make up rights
where they don't exist lie to you about
them and then when we say hold on a
second let's just start with the two
that are in trying number one and the
number two that protects number one oh
what are you an absolutist yeah now
let's look at where the left is mad the
left is mad
that allegedly in two months the supreme
court may not recognize you're right
to force a state
to give you the right to abortion up
until including birth period
we're just talking about the
restrictions here in the first trimester
everything else gets kicked to the
states let's be clear about that they're
mad about that who are what are
conservatives matter and i will tell you
i am mad about this i meant that they
lied about this this is not a release
this is not something that was disclosed
to the public leftists are mad about the
fact that uh abortion isn't found as
right in the constitution they're mad at
the constitution really conservatives
myself are mad about the league we're
mad about something actually
unprecedented i'm mad about the torch
mob
trying to now exact justice themselves
we have a process this is why if you
look at the polls they recently came out
joe biden is i think the worst polling
that's come out not only of joe biden
but a democratic ticket a generic
democratic ticket versus republican
ticket is the issue of rule of law hey
hold on a second rule of law what are we
black lives matter riots you can't write
they said well the right is the language
of the unheard okay
we talk about hey hold on a second this
is breaking the law
former vice president joe biden uh
hunter biden i just get the biden's
confused because there's so many pieces
of [ __ ]
so
we say hey hold on a second the problem
is you're breaking
the law and so the left believes that
the right believes in the rule of law
right now you look at the left they're
mad with what will be the rule of law
better legal reasoning at the supreme
court
so they're mad with rule of law and
republicans are mad at the breaking of
rule of law that a crime has been
committed in leaking this and there have
been plenty not just again we we want to
use the mainstream left their platform
use republicans that most of whom i
don't even like you have people like tom
cotton josh holly rick scott and i
believe that uh senator small hands mark
rubio probably said it best he said the
next time you hear the far left
preaching about how they are fighting to
preserve a republic's institutions and
norms remember how they leaked a supreme
court opinion in an attempt to
intimidate the justices
on
abortion
that's really well said
and i don't even like mark rubio that
much dev you were asking earlier about
um there being some kind of punishment
for this and josh hawley just tweeted
this it should go without saying that if
a justice league this he or she should
face impeachment oh 100 percent
i i appreciate you looking that up i
would assume that yeah anybody who
leaked this kind of information would
have to and i mean anybody who does like
i personally
appreciated the snowden thing and i'm
sure a lot of people agree disagree on
that but it's like i really do think
that
if we don't start getting our government
in check because it's just showing that
not only is the government it's always
people it's always been people it's why
it's a flood system but it's becoming
more and more flawed as we just give
into these mobs and while this other
side pushes in
constantly saying oh you're flipping
this you're flipping this you're just
gonna create a rule if you got
everything you wanted
you would eventually have three laws
that basically took away every one of
your human rights and we would just be
sitting under communism yeah that's all
that they want and i i don't understand
why they don't
grasp what a free country is a free
society they don't look into the laws
like i enjoy learning about stuff like
that they don't want it well of course
they don't think you're earnest you and
i disagree on things because i mean you
say you're more of a census but the
truth is today like elon musk
you're definitely more conservative
that's even by and i think a lot of
people but you approach it honestly
which i appreciate about you and i know
that even though our audience people
watching are likely more to the right
than you they appreciate that you go
okay what's going on here the thing is
people like the aocs and not just aocs
and elizabeth warren's but people at cnn
they're not approaching it honestly
they're approaching it from how can we
misrepresent this they don't want a free
country well they just i mean you just
watched it again on real time on cnn how
they just change simple words yeah and
say would they want to take away your
right for abortion right
well and also it's an illegal this is a
takeaway you're right for this is we
this is all the things that are meant to
piss you off
so that you start a fire that's it yeah
well they're going to start a fire
because they're not a church mouse no
come on i'm not quiet yeah well church
mouse i mean they just haven't really
they don't have bic lighters that's one
thing
she should put on her cap and go for a
long winter's nap that's what i said
yeah and by winter's nap i mean one from
which you never wake up no
only without the third act yeah yeah it
just means you should be in a play but
you just uh you know you just gave some
uh examples that i do think are
important you just talked about snowden
okay we can a lot of people they bleed
together snowden assange and i think
there is a difference but okay oh yeah i
don't think it was legal what he did no
no but i'm just saying but here's the
point is there is an argument to be made
yeah certainly for both of them and i
think assange and sun are different
let's just say for the sake of argument
now there is certainly an argument to be
made that there is validity for example
to
whistleblowing when you are exposing
corruption when something is illegal
absolutely or not even when something is
illegal but something that harms the
american populace right let's say a back
room deal something that is pulling the
wool over their eyes something that is
deliberately pernicious watergate right
now leaking
what corruption are you exposing
what illegality are you exposing what
are you blowing the whistle on that
judges are doing their job that's how
you differentiate you go oh
this is designed to intimidate
oh okay got it
hey wait hold on a second does it help
does it cnn
does it help uh
illuminate the issue for the audience
to stake outside of justice robert's
house in a rapist van
what's the added value there nothing
what's the allied value intimidation
taylor lorenz but that's exactly what
and posting the information of the
parents of the libs of tick tock what's
it what corruption are you exposing are
the parents involved in some sort of
illegal tick-tock ring where they they
they somehow managed to go out and find
publicly posted videos of public
teachers saying share this to
indoctrinate as many kids what's the
corruption that's being exposed none
that's how you
at first pass at first pass again does
it pass a sniff test okay is this a
collateral damage though when it's even
when it's the point right because like
her exposing them yeah it's by her
exposing them you're endangering them
and all their family that's innocent and
all of your family that's innocent who
doesn't want to be exposed because now
people are pissed off at you they're
going to go after them right everything
that she went about in that way was
wrong yes so yeah i don't even that's
what i mean i don't even look at it as
like a collateral damage thing it's a
deliberate thing to create all damage to
be that right no that's exactly what it
is that's the difference between whistle
blowing there's there's a purpose to it
the context of it is different versus
just leaking private information in an
unprecedented way in a criminal way in
order to try and silence and intimidate
to get your way so what does this mean
though this really means right with roe
v wade
uh uh chief justice launches
investigation on leak of roe
draft opinion let's see elizabeth warren
who looks like a kindergarten boy
right to an abortion for some woman who
can't support the children she set her
limo to take her to hogwarts
trying to keep her family together let's
get them on the record voting on that
and if we don't have enough votes to
pass it now
we get everybody on the record and then
we take that to the public in november
we've got less than 200 days until
election day roe versus wade and that's
the reason for that is intimidation
it's trying to scare people they're
trying to gin up riots and protests
right now so that people stay home and
don't vote or they're trying to convince
enough people out there that the right
is as extreme as they are believing that
you know kids should be put on puberty
blockers this is what your former vice
president said that affirming your
child's gender meaning
not their gender is one of the the most
important things you can do they're
trying to say look at how extremist the
right is they're trying to remove your
right to abortion let's make sure that
message is heard up until and including
elections this isn't any different than
the playbook where kamala harris said
they should keep rioting that's what
they did back then what did you just say
if we don't have the votes if we can't
go through the legislative process if we
can't go through rule of law you know
sort of like the process that we also
understand with the filibuster and you
know not packing the supreme court we're
just going to abandon it and try and
intimidate people with the power of the
audience and then they try and frame
that as democracy that's not democracy
that's r that's mob rule let me see if
she's still on there
isn't that coercion i don't know law but
isn't it
in a matter of speaking
i mean yeah i guess it's a roundabout
term but it seems that way i don't think
it's a roundabout term i think it's a
it's pretty way of the bird redirection
as as the crow travels yes as the crow's
feet elizabeth warren travel let's go
back to her yes
i bet she's wearing moccasins that we're
gonna after 50 years decide a woman does
not have a right to choose
but then the limits of the supreme court
decision
number one
but even more
equally profound he just went number one
and it would mean that
every other decision he also paid six
russian prostitutes for abortions last
night
i i i realize this goes back a long way
but one of the debates i have with
robert bork was whether
whether
griswold versus connecticut should stand
as law
the state of connecticut said that the
privacy of your bedroom your husband and
wife or a couple could not choose to use
contraception to use the contraceptive
as a violation of the law
if the rationale of the decision as
released
were to be sustained
the whole range of rights are in
question like what a whole range of
rights like what the idea we're letting
like what states make those decisions
i just gave you a list of i don't you
can rewind this probably about 15
minutes you're going to be more likely
to wear condoms is that what he's
talking about i don't know i don't
believe that's actually no that's not
what he saw he was trying to say that
one state said you couldn't use
contraception which is again it's a it's
a red herring it's not something
anyone's talking about right now but
what rights i just gave you an example
of rights that are not in the
constitution that are also not at risk
like the right to privacy all these
pretty much every other example of right
to privacy doesn't include abortion he
just said other rights are at risk name
one
all right token owen here was telling me
that there's something coming in yes we
have breaking news so chief justice john
roberts confirms that the draft of
returning roe v wade is genuine and they
will launch an investigation so i just
saw on cnn that he was going to launch
investigation but they confirmed that it
is authentic all right good well i
didn't waste a whole show well that's
good as long as the fbi and cia are on
it we'll never know yes yes
that's a well they're now they're now uh
they're referred to as memory hole yes
just a guy with the boy's life in the
bathroom oh i got to do something today
no no no no no no bye do something we
mean uh nothing oh good oh great great
i'm going to go continue leaking my
information yeah if you wouldn't mind
i'm on a zoom call
so free let's look at what this uh
actually does as far as it kicks
abortion by kick i mean it gives the
rights back to the states we're just
talking about the idea that states can't
legislate abortion within the first
trimester right that's what people are
complaining about when they're filing
these petitions that go up to the
supreme court if there's a ban on
abortion or if there are any limitations
on abortion within the first trimester
this is why people get really confused
they don't states really already have
the right yeah okay now if this is
overturned the only thing that really
changes is that first trimester
idea this idea of viability it's about
it's it's it's really not
something
as severe as they're making it out to be
it just allows states
to be
more free to make their own decisions
with abortion okay so
the left what they are arguing and
you're seeing this with with uh joe
biden and we just quoted earlier aoc and
uh bernie sanders said it needed to be
codified into law
so they want the federal government
uh to control
abortion regulations so if they had
their way
what does that mean the federal
government would set it basically you
wouldn't have states like colorado or
like california or like connecticut as
they just mentioned with extreme
abortion laws and then states like texas
or mississippi all states would look
like
colorado all states would look like
virginia if the federal government were
in charge of abortion as they see fit
because you can see it on a state level
so let's look at the extreme right
versus the extreme left the most extreme
anti-abortion laws uh would be those
like oklahoma's right the fetal
heartbeat protection bill now you may
not agree with it but the idea is
there's a heartbeat
can't abort it
once there's a heartbeat can't abort it
right these are the kinds of extreme
laws that they vehemently oppose said
the church mouse they're like oh it's
like you can't well a second whose
heartbeat is it you still have to answer
that question they don't want to answer
the question they just say it's about a
woman's choice okay so the woman has two
hearts what is she a rainbow trout now
don't fact-check me i'm not exactly
entirely sure which fish it is that has
two hearts someone can comment below and
let me know i know there is a fish that
has two hearts though so i'm half right
so those two trouts are pretty nice
either way too fishy it's like the no
not to eat just to be friends oh okay
yeah yeah yeah
well they're they're fluid they're very
they're fluid influences
it is a trap by the way it is a trout
two hearts
i didn't even know that the rainbow
trout
uh might not be a rainbow trout they're
called it says trout okay all right well
i like trout i don't like trout
i like to look at them yeah they're fun
to look at or so i particularly like it
when there's a trout on a plaque and
you're like oh my gosh that's a nice and
then it goes smoke on the water and you
go ah
what a wonderful gift this is great that
this took over the 90s thank you uncle
scott i still have it i didn't have
enough door stops yes i guess you didn't
know me at all so i thought i'd like
this let's look at the most extreme
right versus the extreme left
let's just the right is not arguing for
the federal government to control
access to abortion they're arguing that
states have these rights at this point
at least as far as it relates to roe v
wade and so even though at the most
extreme example if they you'd have a
heartbeat law you may not agree with it
but i don't think that's
crazy extremist on the left you have
democrats like former thank god virginia
governor ralph northam uh advocating for
and i don't want i'm putting in quotes
but hold on a second i was going to say
infanticide but hold on let me just
infanticide the infant would be
delivered
the infant would be kept comfortable
the infant would be resuscitated if
that's what the mother and the family
desired and then a discussion would
ensue between the physicians and the
mothers
uh and this is something and all
references are available louder with
credit.com we'll also have a link to
this undercover uh abortion video that
we did a while back which you can't find
on youtube this was absolutely uh shadow
ban so not as many people saw it uh
it's like 90 of the videos like this
that we had done
uh this is undercover work in colorado
here's what abortion looks like there
meet we'll call her patient x she was at
this colorado abortion clinic to kill
her 29 week old potential baby rose how
far along are you i'm 28.
and as we later found out it was
actually worse to get your ultrasound
yeah
32 weeks
32 weeks so let's do the math for people
who let's because this is something they
often just say and i'm going to do this
if it sounds like uh
if it sounds like i'm being uh a
pedantic i am
certainly a pedestrian a lot of people
yes
um
let's go through it so hopefully you'll
remember it because i often throw around
terms like 20 years two weeks in a year
yes so four weeks is a month let's go by
four weeks so four weeks one
eight weeks two
twelve weeks three
16 weeks four
20 weeks five
24 weeks six
28 weeks seven
she thought she was at seven months
i had twins who were delivered at eight
and a half weeks
there's no argument that even before we
get to 32 months months oh sorry weeks
months yeah that would have been weird
yeah
they'd just be finger puppets exactly
[Laughter]
so there is no argument there at
viability
and by the way the viability argument
keeps moving up because we have better
technology
no one's arguing at this point that
that's not a baby at 28 weeks seven
months
at 32 weeks eight months no one's
arguing that you just saw the governor a
former governor of virginia he's not
arguing and he's saying well if the baby
is born then we'll because it doesn't
matter look
it matters
to me it matters to people who are
pro-life here's the big difference to
people who are pro-life and how
aggressive are they going to be well
they're going to be out there on the
sidewalk
uh protesting abortion
it matters to us because seven months
eight months is a life that should
matter if you're pro-choice it should
but it doesn't
it doesn't on the main and the
mainstream leftist platform it doesn't
and it can't the democrat party cannot
say that matters so it matters to us
which is why we focus on what a life is
it doesn't matter to the left because
they're fine with abortion up to seven
months eight months nine months anyway
and so they say uh
my body my choice but
is it a life
the question is never answered
and that's what it comes down to
if you can't answer the question
what is a life if you cannot answer that
question
i i'm sorry it's your opinion on
abortion is not as valid as somebody who
is
willing to have some skin in the game
and answer that question you have to be
able to que to answer that question to
actually be able
to tell me where you stand
certainly to argue it
in the courts
i've never heard elizabeth warren i've
never heard bernie sanders i've never
heard former vice president biden i've
never heard president kamala harris
define what a life is
because you won't find it
it doesn't
matter
and that's why they have to lie and and
by the way speaking of leaks because
we're going to be talking about this
more on on mud club uh it is just it
still smells it really does and this is
the second day it smells it's terrible
it's why i grew a mustache and my mug is
fine but to smell something else oh god
oh no dip it in the fine look colognes
what
oh
dude come on it is
amber hurt it's a copycat pooping and
this has been going on all week you know
what let's get to the bottom of this
[Music]
i don't mean to laugh
i just think's in here man it's
disgusting i know that's a crime that's
a crime i just i just thought the amber
heard comparison was humorous yeah but
it's a crime dave it is a crime it's not
a laughing matter no somebody's been
leaking it all over the place someone's
been pooping angrily which is what's
most disturbing is roe v wade in it
everywhere who is doing this uh
i'm not doing it i don't i i think okay
look i think i saw i saw brandon's is
staying a little late last night what
i've had my suspicions all right guys uh
uh maximus send brendan in can we send
brennan get to the bottom let's get
ready right here yeah we're going to get
to the bottom of this
all right okay here's even brendan
obviously works here wonderful editor uh
yes even brennan good man
i'm gonna ask you and i ask you once
okay
why are you pooping in our mugs and
placing them on our furniture that's two
steps
hold on a second let me let me make sure
i can't hear you why are you pooping on
our furniture and or mugs
where is that happening
it's right next brendan it's right next
there's there's crap in the chair right
next to you okay you put it yeah right
there right next to you let's be honest
i couldn't have done that
and why is that
because
i have a peanut allergy
it's true god he's right he's ruined
every field trip we've ever had yep
we're not allowed to have reese's cups
in the office
and there is a peanut
in that piece of [ __ ]
actually come to think of it i think i
might have some video evidence of who
might be the perpetrator tim could you
roll that clip um oh yeah oh dude right
yeah
all right awesome make sure you get this
okay remember the pole
yeah now i'm going to use this trash can
to wall jump to here
and then climb up this pole i've done it
in mario wait sorry i'm getting i'm
getting uh i'm getting a phone call
right now
let me just pick that up
well way to provide non-evidence luna no
look he was walking you can slow it down
you can yeah tim can you go back and
reverse and enhance um yeah hold on uh
what am i looking at all right luna is
walking on the back with a mug
uh rewinding oh wait a minute you're
talking about this yeah look
back to the right
dude
that's him walking out the bathroom with
mugs well that's circumstantial at best
is that triple fisted that's
circumstantial at best you know okay we
don't have we don't have any more time
for this brendan okay fine you're off
the hook for right now for right now
we have to test it later and feed him a
payday bar we'll see what happens
you know but you are still in you're
still in you're still fired all right
you know let's just let's you can you
can take us out
[Music]
sorry we've gone late because i've been
transfixed by cnn's not
by cnn's non-experts lying to you about
the supreme court so we're going to go
right now we're going to go to mud club
and actually have a we're going to talk
about how generation z is a bunch of uh
racists uh and also you know what you
know what let's just have more of a
discussion
as well yes
oh yeah i have a story because i went to
starbucks because i ran out of coffee
beans this morning and there was a woman
there was a a lady who made a comment
about dave chappelle where if she were a
man i would have hit her
so uh
we'll talk about this and more about the
supreme court in a way that we can't
talk on you youtube uh
we love you and if you're on rumble go
to mug club but youtube you can piss off
you